.
♪ ♪ ♪
- À Brasilia, des centaines
d'évangéliques se sont
rassemblés sur la place des
Trois Pouvoirs pour prier pour
le présiBolsonaro
durant les deux heures du tout
dernier débat télévisé
d'une interminable campagne.
Ce n'est pas eux que Bolsonaro
doit convaincre dans le studio
de TV Globo. Il a besoin des
indécis et des abstentionnistes
du premier tour pour rattraper
son retard sur l'ex-présiden
Lula.
(clis d'appareils photo)
En présence de ses conseillers,
dont le juge Sergio Moro, devenu
sénateur, qui a mis Lula en
prison il y a quatre ans,
Jair Bolsonaro est repassé
à l'attaque. Mensonge. Ment
Ce sont les mots qui ont été
le plus entendus des deux côtés
pendant les deux heures
de débat. En fait de débat,
plutôt deux monolplis
d'invectives : Lula a été traité
de voleur, bandit, chef de
mafia, de corrompu
scandale de Petrobras. Lula a
marqué des points à propos de la
pandémie. Il promet de redonner
au Brésil son prestige perdu.
"Avec Bolsonaro, le pays
est devenu un paria" dit-il.
iliens vivent avec
anxiété les dernières heures
de la campagne. En jeu, rien
de moins que la démocratie,
de retou989.
FERNANDO CARDOSO LIMA NETO
analyste, Un. Brésil Rio Janeiro
- On doit choisir entre un
projet, un projet autoritaire
qui menaeaux les plus
élémentaires de démocratie et
un autre qui, même si on n'est
pas d'accord avec ses propres
projets politiques, au niveau
économique, au niveau social,
au moins, c'est un projet
qui reste dans le cadre
de la démocratie.
- Pourtant, les Brésiliens
tiennent à la démocratie,
c'est le choix politique de 79 %
d'entre eux. Mais presque la
moitié d'entre eux vont voter
pour quelqu'un qui la menace.
- En fait, ça, c'est unesituatis
paradoxes de la démocratie.
Parce que partout dans le monde,
les gens manifestent leur
adhérence à la démocratie. Mais
en même temps, ils manifestent
aussi leurs critiques aux partis
politiques, qui sont justement
la caractéristique principale
d'une démocratie. Il n'y a pas
de démocratie sans
politiques.
- Jair Bolsonaro a dit et
on lui a fait répéter qu'il
respecterait le ré
élections. Il a dit : "celui
qui a le plus de vote gagne".
Reste à savoir que s'il perd
avec un rès serrrès serrrès ser,
il ne va pas prétendre qu'il y a
eu fraude, comme il l'a laissé
entendre maintes fois
auparava
Jean-Michèle Leprince,
Radio-Canada, Rio